Earlier civilizations had different and
arguably more sophisticated perceptions
of time. In most pre-modern cultures the
past hovered over the present. Ancestors
were felt to be watching. Past and future
generations were understood to be
knitted into one fabric. The medieval
Scandinavian worldview included the
concept of 'wyrd,' loosely fate, or the
power of the past to shape the present
and future. Wyrd was embodied in the
world tree Yggdrasil, which gives
structure to all of time and space. It
was maintained by the mysterious female
Norns
who water it from an ancient and
continuously replenishing well while
reciting the orlog,
the eternal laws that hold
up the world. In Ghanaian tradition
there's the concept of 'Sankofa,'
usually symbolized by a backward-looking
bird and associated with the proverb: "It
is not wrong to go back for that which
you have forgotten." In other words: move
forward but remember the past.
There's the Buddhist concept of 'Sati,'
usually translated as mindfulness, but
actually something closer to memory of
the present, suggesting a subtler
relationship with time. In these
traditions and many others, the past
present and future coexist and interact
in ways much more nuanced than our
simplistic linear view of time. In our
culture, we tend to mistake technological
prowess for wisdom. The people we call
visionaries base their conceptions of
the future on the notion that we should
do everything in our power to circumvent
the irksome constraints of the natural
world that have shackled hapless
denizens of the past—not appreciating
that earth is so much more powerful and
more patient than we are, and will always
prevail. The idea that earth time just
doesn't apply to us leads to the
delusion that we can outsmart the
complex system of biogeochemical cycles
and, for example, magically solve our
climate woes through stratospheric sulfate
injection, and expect that there won't be
a powerful backlash of unintended
consequences as with contra dancers
reorganize themselves. Disrespect for
time also seduces us into thinking that
we could skip over all that inefficient
of years of coevolution stuff and just
terraform ourselves another planet.
Engineering the climate or terraforming
Mars sound easy if you're completely
unaware of the intrinsic timescales of
geological and biological phenomena, the
deep evolutionary pathways that gave
rise to the world we live in, the
intricately choreographed
behind-the-scenes biogeochemical cycles,
the housekeeping crew that make earth
habitable. Such ideas are beyond hubris,
revealing not only a profound ignorance
of the earth but also of human nature.
What makes us think we could
successfully change the rules that
govern this or another planet when we
haven't even learned to govern ourselves?